[Musique]
j'ai envie de voir la famille voilà j'ai
envie de vous voir encore
j'ai une chambre là-bas
la chambre des petits pourquoi toi tu es
quoi maintenant un grand
reste avec mon chéri
[Musique]
balance pourquoi tu es revenu c'est
chaud j'arrive pas à le dire tu es pas
mal j'espère non je suis pas malade
David David j'ai demandé le baptême et
je vais me faire baptiser t'es pas
sérieux là tu veux pas te convertir au
catholicisme mais je sais quoi ça j'ai
trouvé dans la valise pas avec les
doigts
tu changes de Dieu change tes parents
fais-toi adopter on n'a pas envie de te
perdre
je le fais pour moi pour être plus
proche de marée c'est la femme parfaite
pour toi vous vivez ensemble mais elle
te fous la paix c'est pas toi que je
vais expliquer ce que c'est que de
perdre un fils pourquoi tu nous fais pas
une crise à cinquantaine comme tous ces
mecs là tu t'achètes une voiture de
sport très basse tu te tapes une petite
nana très haute et qui arrête de nous
emmerder la maison juive tu peux
chercher la sortie personne n'a jamais
trouvé ça va je suis en train de répéter
un truc je me prépare en fait
[Musique]
il faut me sortir c'est une compétition
d'apnée
[Musique]